all right people of the internet retro
wrecking tour here just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell welcome
back to our second playthrough of
Hogwarts Legacy and we are getting ready
to do
our first unforgivable spell
if you've been following this series you
know in our first playthrough we didn't
do any unforgivables we were a good
Gryffindor which is what we want to play
that's who I really am however
I've been seeing how much fun
everybody's having with these dark arts
so we gotta do a second playthrough man
Lord retro Mort has been created off
stream we've been doing some work off
stream
look at this look at this the daily the
the daily and keys Quest we completed
that one
over on Twitch with the live audience
that was fun we knocked that out so
we're probably going to be rocking these
robes for the rest of the game
but
it is time ladies and gentlemen in the
shadow of the bloodline Sebastian and
ominous were seen arguing in the Great
Hall I should find out what this is all
about
so we are going to head to the Great
Hall
we actually saw them in there earlier
when I was doing the daily and keys we
saw them there
so I'm pretty sure this is
the crucio quest
you're Sebastian right here see what's
up what were you Anonymous speaking
about he's being ridiculous
apparently Salazar Slytherin had a
secret scriptorium here in Hogwarts yeah
to use for the dark arts so he wants
nothing to do with it I reminded him
that Anne needs to cure this scriptorium
could hold the answers we need
Than People realize the gaunts know this
better than most perhaps I've spoken out
of turn ominous family history is
personal to him oh it's a it's no green
screen moon it's my actual uh background
I'd like to know more about it if you
wouldn't mind telling me I won't repeat
it very well
but do keep this between us ominous
learned dark magic from his parents
are you familiar with the Christmas I've
heard of it
I've heard of it
crucial correct the cruciatus curse
also known as the torture curse
excrucially he looks some victim he
looks ready to learn parents and older
siblings had no qualms about casting us
on Muggles for sport ominous described
the sound of the victim's cries as
horrific so the first time he was asked
to cast it himself as a child
couldn't bring himself to do it as
punishment his family casteth on him the
anguish was so bad that when asked cast
it again he relented I have repeatedly
ominous he did what he had to
but he still hasn't forgiven himself
he had no choice he should have known
better
that's awful
but no matter the circumstance he should
never have casted he should have known
better trust me it's not as easy as you
might assume thinking straight when
you've been hit with crucio wait that's
almost like a thrift between ominous the
Goody Two-Shoes answer whoops that is oh
well I came along every moment he isn't
Hogwarts he's with us in feldcroft
trusts me and more often than not he
winds up listening to me I'll remind him
of that when I follow up about
scraptorium watch for my owl I'll have
news soon enough
I'll make ominous understand he'll
change his mind I'll make ominous
understand
yikes dude
see those are the kinds of comments man
when I'm like people love this guy
people love Sebastian come on
I'll make him understand oh
all right so can we not start the quest
yet we probably have to do we have to do
something else to
to get it to move along
we could just go and do
let's just uh we can attend our
astronomy class
that's something we need to do anyway
all right so let's go ahead and go to
our map
we should just be able to go straight to
the astronomy wing
why did I feel like there's a moon right
here
is that one no that's I think that's the
mirror okay let's just do what we came
here for
get Gladwin we'll we'll tackle that
another day
and your reading is the Dragon
Professor Shaw is that the one you
didn't like
perhaps you're due for an adventure
there's a meat ladies
oh dude they were kind of eyeing us
weren't they
I think it's the I think it's the new
robe
I think it's that house Relic Road
Heavens remain hazy to The Starry Eyed
now if you were to devote yourselves to
persistent and painstaking observation
you just might hey thank you for the
follow with that didn't
take your telescopes tonight we will be
on the observation deck
if you guys haven't completed out all
the astronomy tables yet
some of the coolest robes in the game
you've got to be the new song Forever
you know
[Music]
here I can adjust that for you no no
bring it
on your own
okay R to focus oh
there we go
I thought I went too far but no I guess
not
in your outside of class is that clear
but Professor it's freezing out
Mia Cole didn't stop the Great Stuff
Oleander
astronomy tables they erected throughout
the highlands from which they gazed
Millennia ago on the very self-same
stars above us
is that clear
dismissed
it's she's like not impressed
not impressed
hello I don't believe we've met
officially I'm Amit I'm something of an
astronomy buff hello omit it's nice to
meet you did I hear Professor Shaw say
that you don't have your own telescope
I have an experience wish we had more
meat in the game
he could have definitely been like a
full-on Ravenclaw companion
that's very kind of you omit are you
sure you won't need it I'm certain
it's my old one something I've already
finally got my hands on something like
that
you've heard of it I assume I mean of
course you have it's only the Pinnacle
of all personal stargazing implements
actually no but my old models never too
shabby either I haven't heard of it
Goblin cut class First Rate Optical
enchantments hate to think such a fine
instrument is just collecting dust well
I thank you Amit think nothing of it
anyway the telescopes in the storage
room right underneath us you can't miss
it I have some uh reading to finish on
the lower deck I think there's a field
guy page up here too bring the telescope
there's something I want to talk to you
about
rebellious
where's it at over here yeah there it is
astronomy telescope this telescope is
the finest stargazing instrument of its
kind perfect for viewing the moon and
the stars and anything else one might
find in the night sky
dog isn't it okay yeah it's down there
then isn't there
I might be thinking of the allery I feel
like there's a page that flies around
all right so let's go down here
oh okay we can get that one
and something in here
a wig and weld potion
this was his old telescope
particularly brand new
ah
all right what am I supposed to do now
go back and talk to him
Rebellion
there he is
the perfect night for I have the
telescope it's nicer than I'd expected I
would not offer a prospective Stargazer
a third or eight Luna scope yeah he does
he does uh join you on a main quest
um
yes what is it you remember those
astronomy table saw was going on about
it just so happens I've been reading up
on them a little myself and it seems
there may be one right here at Hogwarts
I believe we could use it to find hidden
constellations
I have a feeling I would be attached to
that game with a catch dude
bribe you or anything
but mm-hmm
how do you win no one from the gobstones
club will go with me said they'd rather
get spit out by a stone then
well they are cowards let us get moving
while the stars are still out I'll show
you how to use that telescope once we
get there I promise
all right I suppose he wants to be a
companion right trust me he wants to be
practically every
every shall we
oh dude the robe looks so good in the
cutscene
look at that
the table is on a castle wall ahead look
for a stone platform something that
doesn't quite belong
why are you lagging behind there you go
some say the locations of the tables
were originally marked by centaurs for
ritual stargazing
huh
it is nice having a fellow Stargazer
where you at dude where are we going
happy to be here walk it is good to
leave the classroom now and then come on
man
it's not that creepy out here at night
is it the garbstones club are cowards
here I am charging ahead
why don't you lead the way if you're
sure
which way you want me to go dude
want me to lead the way right here
reporting a few cobwebs and some dust
nothing to be concerned about nothing to
be concerned it's just not as
I expected we haven't got this yet
caged bathtub this bathtub has been kept
behind lock and key for as long as
anyone can remember rumor has it that
the tub was enchanted to chase after
students decades ago who were too
obsessed with their studies to care much
for personal hygiene
wow
all right so we probably need to do
incendio maybe
and then
oh just just destroy them okay
what do we have here
get rid of the spider web
Fighters might be lurking about
oh no I'm not this close to school I
meet
here we go
the constellation should appear near the
center of your view
oh wow you have to really zoom in on
that one
got it
I was right about the tables they really
are gateways to the far Stars just as
the book said and your contribution was
invaluable rest assured you shall be
credited in my Memoirs one day
whatever you say I'll meet whatever you
say
oh you wait you are going to be quoting
whatever you say I mean this is only the
beginning you will find more tables like
this one throughout the grounds and
Forest all beckoning to be discovered by
a worthy astronomer and if I have ever
seen one it's you oh and about my old
telescope don't bother returning it you
keep it quite generous well thank you
sir you are welcome
I know his robe and The Gobbledy cooking
must be a windy night you know his hair
though
and how you pronounce your ass
um anyway glad our adventure was a
success I will see you soon
all right
find astronomy tables done okay now
let's see has Sebastian
he hasn't reached back out yet
that was a main quest though
no I thought we'd be able to just do
that Quest right away
let me check my mail let's see if we
have anything from him
or is he at dude there he is
foreign
we already did that one
so why
I keep
we have to learn when guardian Leviosa
before we can do that
cast a pulso on a levitated enemy
hey yeah hey good use of the new email
there with the letters
all right so I mean maybe we just have
to do this one
okay do we have a venomous tentacula and
do we have a mandrake
we do and we do
all right perfect so let me read again
exactly what we need to do here we just
have to use that one and this one we
have to use on multiple enemies
simultaneously and then garlic will
teach us
Wingardium Leviosa
it's Leviosa
not leviosol
all right let's see what would be a good
place to go
all right we've got a bandit camp
let's see where's the nearest Bandit
Camp there's one right there so we could
get this flu flame here and then fly in
there
on another adventure are we
all right so let's just go straight to
the Bandit camp
oh wait hold on on our way
I just
it is so convenient having all of the
flu flames and then when you go to a new
game and you don't have any of them
you recognize that really fast
and honestly I mean it's fun to just
travel normally in this game but when
you're going around at the end just
trying to collect stuff
yeah having all of them is oh there's
one right here too let's go
all right so
okay we got it on multiple enemies
foreign
wolf animagus right there
I know I'm just ignoring that other guy
right now
pretty sure I saw another one flying in
yep
all right had to use a wiggin weld
wait why did I not break the shield
what's happening
finally
no we don't have any red spells ready
all right you know what we still needed
to use another one though we need to use
this one
use it go
get them venomous tentacula
did they finish up Professor spells hey
thank you for the update
keep emphasizing people giving
suggestions help with bug fixes a lot of
ideas mostly fixes for now very cool
very cool appreciate you keeping us
updated on that Professor spells
stop that right now
now you've gone
man this guy has so much health there we
go finally one less poacher in The
Wizarding World all right so I think we
got both of those things complete for
garlic or at least we should have
let's make sure that they went through
there
all right attend herbology class during
the day nice nice nice that's all we
have to do and I think that one is
already marked
hey welcome in to Easton there thank you
for the follow
Anna thank you for being here have a
good one
have a good rest of your Friday
okay wait why did we not why is it not
showing the check mark on the map
maybe because we have to grab this
or this over here
there it is that's what gives you the
check mark when you actually open that
chest right there
all right so now let's go let's just go
back to the school
and let's go to
uh class with garlic
why is it not showing up on the map
what am I missing
I mean should it not be showing up
oh well it's fine I mean I see it I see
a little indicator right there but
what the Christie hey welcome in
oh because you're flying
see
no it's still not showing it
oh well I mean we're right there anyway
well sure I'll take some of those
[Music]
all right
oh man even the students look terrified
of the cabbages
they are terrified
[Music]
okay so let's learn wingardium from
Professor garlic here's my assignments
professor pleased to hear it Professor
Weasley will be too I'll be sure to let
her know how well you're coming along
thank you professor professor heckett
tells me she taught you levioso so you
should be ready for a more advanced
levitation charm on Guardian Mirabelle
because a bit of concentration she's so
sweet graceful wand movement
but try your hand at it
just so sweet her whole demeanor
all right let's go triangle
we gotta go back down
Wingardium Leviosa
all right that's it
[Music]
levitation charm Wingardium Leviosa can
levitate move objects control its
position with your movement and use
up down left right to fine tune its
distance in rotation and you can also
you don't even need to map it because
accio will
accio will automatically
do it for you
okay so that's what spins it around left
and right on the d-pad
Professor garlic a moment of your time
please interesting so now's as good a
time as any
what made you want to teach her balance
I was wondering what made you want to
teach herbology how
I've always had an
I had a thrilled to be asked to step in
for my old herbology Professor he'd had
us immediately after graduation oh dear
a shame for him but it worked out well
for you well
he never cared but really cared for the
plants and they could sense it
be surprised how perceptive a plant can
be at any rate the trouble began one day
when he cut into a Wigan tree
unfortunately for him its thieves were
hiding a bow tackle you may recall The
Marvelous creatures that resemble a twig
I don't remember the story from my first
place
verifying I'd imagine
likely for the professor too and that's
when you took over as the herbology
professor well no quite after three
weeks at Saint mungo's my predecessor
regained a tiny bit of his eyesight he
insisted on returning to the greenhouse
within a week he had he claims by
accident kicked a Chinese chomping
cabbage so it was back to Saint mungo's
for him
oh man I'm gonna say it I'm gonna say it
a fair bit of bad luck there I'd say hmm
well
him but
I got my sympathy for that
person he's not like that
Lord retro Mort though we had to laugh
ing leave of absence continues to this
day
I feel sorry boring I'll just say I'm
glad things it did and that you're the
herbology professor now very kind of you
to say I do love these Gardens and
helping my students grow
speaking with you have a wonderful day
oh and remember
got it
all right so we just learned Wingardium
Leviosa which now means we can complete
the main quest
I'm wondering if you have to complete a
certain number of those before Sebastian
will reach back out again about the
scriptorium Quest
because what's that that's like two now
that we've done since we talked to him
initially
all right so this one's the high keep
meet Natty near
fallbarton Castle
oh dude this if this is the mission that
I think it is this is absolutely Epic
if this is the mission I think it is
I could be wrong though I could be wrong
it might not be time for that mission
just yet
all right so you know what I'm gonna set
a marker for this because
I want to get that when we go over there
to
oh here's a little traveling vendor
right here
don't need anything from you right now
sir
but what I do need is this blue flame
right here
oh wait what do you need what seems to
be the problem
of death but
she wants an invisibility potion I'll be
all right won't I
is an invisibility pool yeah yeah that's
what I need
I have some well as it happens I have
what you need here not sure if it'll
help you though be careful won't you oh
you're a gym you are I'll be sure to be
very careful and you be careful too no
Grim is going to get me thanks to you
kind child wow that's crazy something
better than the official series a
YouTube that you accept this small token
of me karate look at this
or killed
dude what do you guys think
I think it's part of the goblin
Rebellion that killed the aura
and then bother some beasts what has
gotten into them yeah we know about that
that could be that could very well be
mentioning us and
big and what happened on our journey
this place has seen better days
we absolutely need a photo mode I
totally agree photo mode will be awesome
I put that in my video of things I would
love to see added
I feel like that's definitely a thing
they will add I think it's just a matter
of like how long will it take
because they're trying to get another
game out you know on a whole
different system
all right so
[Music]
go ahead and grab these while we're over
here
and then let's activate the quest
with Natty
for pindo you're ready to teach me
something else garlic already
see if Sebastian reaches out now too
come on
oh darn it over here maybe after this
maybe after this Quest I'm glad that you
received my
app we need to stay low and
what's going on why are we all the way
out here as promised I did some
investigating to find out what Hollow is
up to
the hog's head this is I know it's the
highway Mission isn't it all I could see
was that it was signed by and bore the
Seal of Victor Rookwood and after you
told me that Rookwood and Hollow were
after you I decided that you were the
perfect person to join me in taking them
down for good
that letter is the tangible proof that
offers a singer needs it is why I
followed Hollow here and why I wrote to
you I need your help to retrieve it
I'll help you find the latinati I'm glad
let's do it
but we should still try to be as quiet
as possible Hollow is here after all
yeah the end of this mission
oh my goodness one of the coolest in the
game
one of the coolest in the game
all right so we need to go around I
think she said but what is this
oh
no one enters unless they're with the
pack or the ash winders
anything you take from unwelcome guests
get split do not leave until you've been
relieved by your replacement
all right I think we go over here to get
in Rebellion
oh wait
so
hold on there's something over there too
wait can we get in this way
okay wait we probably have to burn it
away first right yep
you got stuck on this one your first
time
I mean maybe this is how I came in the
first time I did this Quest but I don't
remember or maybe I'm just discovering
something else right now never seen this
before I'm kind of I don't remember
doing this
okay so that looks like that would lead
us up
to the Merlin puzzle
so then where does this take us
all right we need to cat oh look at the
little rat
I need to cast lumos
oh there's a chest back here
unidentified hand item okay
I was about to say man imagine if there
was another way to to get into the area
where we're trying to go for the mission
okay well that was cool
oh we can't hop on the Broom right now
all right let's just go back this way
because I'm pretty sure this is the way
that we're supposed to go
for the quest
yeah we can climb up right here
and right here
a wonderful
did it I wonder
oh no you can't fit through there
open
okay that's two upgrades now I might as
well go ahead and do it I think we had
an upgrade on
the gloves
oh wow one okay I'm still gonna do it
and then we had an upgrade on
was it the Hat
yeah the hat right there
we're gonna go back
take it off okay two upgrades two
upgrades
hey welcome in to Espresso thank you for
the follow welcome in
Rebellion
all right we're supposed to get this out
of here right
oh no
are we completely stuck oh this is not
good
this is not good
okay let's
destroy this get all this out of the way
okay wait hold on I have another idea
levioso it and now
oh no
oh thank goodness okay we got out
all right now if we do
there we go
afraid we had glitched it for a second
nicely done
revelio
I need to find a way into the Gatehouse
to open the gate for Natty
okay you can do that
Rebellion
all right just making sure I'm not
missing anything over here first which
we would have look at that another
upgrade on some gloves
all right I'm gonna check it imagine if
it's just one point again imagine
imagine
a five all right it was worth it
definitely worth it for that one
go back to the dark arts
okay
let's see should we cast probably
levioso first right wait how do we oh we
have to go I remember this now it's
coming back to me we have to go to the
other side
and do this
get that out of the way now we can go
back around
these roads are so cool dude they're so
cool
that looks as if it might raise the gate
Rebellion
I thought there was something else in
here oh just another note
don't blast it
don't blast the gate
all right so then we have some a ladder
right there
a lock
that we cannot interact with
you
we're done I will be right up okay so
now Natty can get through
I knew you could
do odd raccoon thank you for the follow
oh she's gonna take care of that door
all right is there anything else I feel
like hold on
I feel like there's something else in
here
we're supposed to get
oh you can't make that jump
how about if we have it over here
what about if we have it right up next
to that
up there and then right really
wait so what's the point of that you
think I mean clearly you're supposed to
be able to get up there
maybe just not right here
all right let's see where that ladder
leads to
ladders right here
okay that just leads out there
all right I don't think there's any
point in doing that part right now
still want to know how to get up there
though
maybe it's gonna lead us up there anyway
that is the main keep my guess is that
we'll find our tiger with the follow
thank you thank you welcome in once we
get
hear them
no I guess there's another way to do it
[Music]
High wing
do you know that hippogriff
that look very well do you know that
epigraph I get the evidence and you free
that's hippogriff agreed
blasted
could it be another way to get lost it
somewhere
yeah this way right here honey I hope
Nazi stays out of trouble
oh well
yeah we need a we need an ads command on
Twitch
I need to make a command for that
people always complain about the ads
guys if I could if I could do something
about it I would I would
foreign
don't blast it I know right
don't blast it
we just got an upgrade there too all
right let's check it out see if it's
I usually don't go into the menu unless
we oh we can't equip it yet
it's only plus four too
all right well we still never found
secret back in that other room I don't
even if it was a secret but there was
definitely a spot that was higher up we
just couldn't get to it
all right so I'm just kind of exploring
making sure we
okay there is something
that's down below though
okay
what are we supposed to do with you
the pulso Maybe
uh yeah we're going hard mode
and Evil on this playthrough
so we first playthrough was good
Gryffindor no unforgivables at all on
our first playthrough
this time evil Slytherin hard mode
mainly sticking to the story stuff I
mean we've been doing some side quests
just to
just to level up and things but and
obviously we'll have to do the ones for
the unforgivables
all right I still wanna I'm I'm so
there's a chest right there so there is
definitely a way to get up there guys
I'm telling you man it looks like we
should just be able to
no not that
maybe we just need to get it a little
bit close like right there yeah okay
that's in the perfect excuse you
the heck was that
okay stay right there
you're trying a seven curse challenge
you mean like only using seven spells
throughout the game or
it doesn't look like it's levitating
that high either
you guys saw me
saw me just tried that
we just tried that
five minutes ago and it did not work
what the heck
all right I'm not gonna complain though
all right you ready for the uh
the piece of gear lower than what we
have
Boom the gold trim Debonair ensemble
I know Christy don't you love those new
uh animated emotes I love them so much
all right well
I just now I have the satisfaction at
least
of knowing that we figured out how to do
it
all right so now we need to go this way
though
keep heading up
oh come on jump back up there
all right so we can't get in there right
now
we can't go around this way
okay what are we supposed to do here if
I can remember
because pretty sure you can't make that
jump into
okay and we can't use our broom right
here
I think it's got to have something to do
with that oh wait can we push it off
yeah there we go and then it's gonna
fall down
the pulso probably
there it goes
all right and then let's bring you out
here Wingardium Leviosa
let's see right in the middle there
all right
I heard something
oh man
boom
that was too funny
I was actually curious if it was gonna
let me
go into stealth
being right behind him
all right you know we probably should do
stealth in this one
even though I love the combat I feel
like this one's meant for you to do
stealth
say hello to Luna ladies and gentlemen
she wants out again surprise right
surprise surprise hey Patrick with the
100 bits
thank you so much Patrick appreciate it
freeze a poacher stalker while they're
readying their tests
nah let's just do that
we're gonna enjoy this
are you though
are you hold on hold on are you
goodbye
stealth is so Opie in this game
it is so op just insta takedown
all right so let's collect that let's
collect that
all right let's do the unlock here hello
Amora
yeah it's it's really powerful
oh wait wait there it is
right there
hey thank you for the follow welcome in
to the new follows hope you guys are
having a good Friday afternoon so far
more rats
all right up we go Nazi's having an
easier time of it I think that's part of
the reason I didn't play much stealth in
my first playthrough I mean I've talked
about it before I just I love the combat
so much
normally in games I always love going
stealth I love going stealth
but something about this game
the combat's just so good I'd rather
just fight but in this area I feel like
this was made for you to be stealth
but then you have stuff like that that
happens like did you okay you did not
see me all right I was about to say
it's just not even fair
no
time to teach someone up we have not
upgraded any of our stealth stuff either
so
let's see where this leads
yeah so what's the point of this little
area
you can walk off here
I'm always so curious like as far as
game design goes you know like what so
like what was the purpose of this area
right here I wonder
because you don't have to come up here
maybe it's just to get a different view
of these enemies I don't know
can I not just walk off there we go
all right let's see how many of these we
can get with stealth right here
you don't see me
you do not see me away from me oh dude
that other one is glitching out behind
it look
look at the one in the back
no I never played Thief
I think my favorite stealth game I
really I enjoyed Dishonored quite a bit
defeated enemy with petrificus totales
we've just done that all right hold on
let's see if we can distract them
okay fine
oh maybe this is what it's for maybe
it's maybe it's for you distract from up
here or something
look at that that one just keeps
climbing up
oh my goodness okay what can I
I need this one to move right here why
are you not moving
you know what we could do is we could
just go crazy with the
could just do ancient Magic on that one
and then see if the other ones detect us
or not
we need like a sniper spell
like a Stupify that I can hit from afar
just Target them right on the head
kind of like an insta takedown or we
just we were just talking about how
stealth is already too powerful so maybe
not maybe not
all right I guess we have to do combat
against you I'm gonna see how close I
can get though
what no way
no way
he's like what my friend just vanished
they just vanished before my eyes
still stuck
he's just he can't get away from that
ledge
all right so wait can you even do
anything about it if I go after your
friend here
[Music]
why why
draconic long coat all right all right
see I told you Dude stealth's too
powerful zero upgrades on my stealth
zero upgrades maybe he's working out
maybe
Dishonored is a
is a good modern take on the old Thief
far easier in comparison oh yeah I did I
remember the Remake yeah
I heard people saying it wasn't wasn't
that great
all right we should be about to
Revenue the final little area up here
this Quest is so good
the end of this quest in particular is
so good
all right so let's go up top
as we creep along
six coins in the cell
all right let's see do we need
all right make sure we haven't missed
anything
actually I think this is just for the
chest over here
yeah that's all that's in this little
spot
Astrid and Manfred
no oh my gosh we just sold everything
but
I guess I'm gonna have to do those
Merlin puzzles on mice on this second
playthrough too
otherwise we have to keep destroying
gear
I don't know I think we can probably get
by without doing too many Merlin trials
on this second playthrough
all right we did get an upgrade though
let's see that's a plus one
that's a plus four but we cannot equip
it just yet
and then we have to change back the
appearance to I think that's what we had
it on right there
I have actually have not messed around
with any of the mods I'm on PS5 so
have not checked out any of the mod
stuff
oh did you do haunted hogs me Damia last
night
it's pretty intense
pretty intense
all right here we go
yes
hi wing and what's the other one's name
caligo or something like that something
with a C I'm pretty sure
you better get on natty
come on
I'm not sure Patrick I'm not sure
all right here we go
wait where's the music oh oh no
no don't ruin this moment
and why is the music not playing I hope
we're not glitched
it's just not the same without the music
I can fix the controller issue though
wow that actually lasted quite a while
we we got the notification
near the end of our last playthrough
but we've been playing a couple of hours
today
all right
here we go oh
dude I think it
it's supposed to have music right
it's it's the wrong music
must be returning from an unscheduled
run
wow
if you don't believe how music can
impact a game
and impact a moment
does this not feel like 10 times less
Epic
without the correct music
it's still playing the the music from
the the mission
unless I'm just crazy and don't remember
it being this
I'm almost positive it's glitching
though
is it not
oh it's so much less
not the same man it's not the same I
want
it's still playing that stealth music
oh that is so disappointing
it's supposed to be playing epic music
right now
it's just not it Just ruins it it's
ruining it I'm so sad
it is incredible but the music's not
here
let's see if we can fix it if we go to
like
no it's still playing it in the
background
it's still playing oh this is my
punishment for interrupting that guy's
workout dude I
you joke but I wonder if that wasn't
part of it if that's when the game
started bugging out
and whatever was happening there
it just could it just carried through
oh
it sounds so wrong
let's see if it fixes now with the
cutscene
no it's still playing that stealth
it was exhilarating wasn't it I wasn't
sure we were going to make it out alive
I'm so sad people watching us later on
YouTube I'm so sorry that moment is
normally so epic straight out of
hollow's house it's so epic I will say I
did not expect still a great moment
but not the same man be on your gut of
course
what did the letter say yeah if it's
still going after this we'll try to
reload the save I'm not sure where he
will find one
but it also includes hallo's orders to
inspect that castle for the poachers
enough to connect Hollow to the crimes I
shall deliver the letter to officer
singer she'll have to do something when
she sees it now tell me where did you
meet these hippogriffs I've only met
hiron before poppy introduced that it's
still playing it he knows a hippogriff
hippogriffs are twitching they are puppy
will be relieved to know that look at
them what what is going on
my mother will be worried I must go
seek me out soon I shall have much to
tell you Natty looks a little off too
all right let's see if it corrects after
this cutscene
no
it's still
ah
oh my gosh
okay let's let's try this let's save
and I'm gonna make sure I save it over
this one just in case all right let's
see if a complete reload of the game
works
yes there we go
all right
it's fixed now
too bad we didn't fix it before that
epic moment
dick tells me he has something to share
with you come on Sebastian we need
Sebastian
where is he
it's crucial Time come on Seb
astian dude you let me down
you let me down Sebastian
I guess it's not time yet I guess we
have to do more side quests
let's see back on the path okay that's
with fig in the map chamber The Lost
Child meet Natty and lower hogsfield
okay so that's for her stuff
to pulso on a levitated enemy
grow and harvest flux weed acquire all
three combat plans using simultaneously
that's to learn flippindo
arresto momentum practice flying near
the spiers practice flying near
Cambridge Tower so that's another
assignment for Madame Kagawa
oh I'm so disappointed man I thought we
were gonna be able to do that right at
the start of the of our game play today
oh I could check that's a good point we
could check and see if we had a
if I had an auto save right before that
I could check on that
and then I could do it again like record
it off stream or something
oh man I was hoping it would pop through
now
for some fun wait to do the spell quest
until after you learn AKA
why is that can you do something uh can
you do something different once you know
it
or does it just make it easier
oh do they actually react on PS5
I didn't know if they would do anything
on PS5 That's funny though
all right well I think we'll call it
there
I think we'll call it there for today